can we go to that
world of psychedelics for for a bit
sure where do you think um
so joe rogan apparently and many others
uh meet
apparently elves when they on dmt
a lot of people report this kind of
creatures that they see
and again it's probably the failure of
language to describe that experience but
dmt is an interesting one
there's a as as you're aware there's a
bunch of studies going on in psychedelic
psychedelics currently mdma um
uh psilocybin in
john hopkins and a bunch of other places
but dmt they all speak of as like
some extra super level
of a psychedelic yeah do you have a
sense of where it is our mind goes
on and second on psychedelics but in
in dmt especially well unfortunately i
haven't taken
dmt so unfortunately or fortunately
unfortunately
unfortunately uh although it's i presume
it's in my body as it is in
uh everyone's brain and in many many
plants
apparently but um i've wanted to take it
i
haven't been i had an opportunity that
was presented itself that where it was
obviously
the right thing for me to be doing uh
but
you know for those who don't know dmt is
is often touted as the most
intense psychedelic and also the
shortest acting i mean you smoke it and
it's
it's basically a 10-minute experience or
a
or a three-minute experience within like
a ten minute window
uh that you when you're really down
after
ten minutes or so um
and terence mckenna was a big proponent
of dmt that was
that was his you know the center of the
bullseye for him psychedelically
apparently
um and it does it is characterized it
seems for many people
by this phenomenon which is which is
unlike virtually any other psychedelic
experience
which is your your it's not just your
perception
being broadened or changed it's you
according according to terence mckenna
feeling fairly
unchanged but catapulted into a
a different circumstance you may have
been shot elsewhere
and find yourself in relationship to
other
entities of some kind right so so the
place is populated with
with things that seem not to be your
mind so it does feel like travel to
another place because you are unchanged
yourself
of course again i just have this on the
authority of the people who described
their experience
but it sounds like it's a pr it's pretty
common it sounds like it's pretty common
for people not to have the full
experience because it's
apparently pretty unpleasant to smoke so
it's like getting enough on board in
order to get
shot out of the the cannon
and land among the what
mechanic called this is uh
self-transforming machine elves
yeah um that appeared to him like
jeweled you know faberge egg like ba
self-dripping basketballs that were
handing him completely uninterpretable
reams of profound knowledge
it's a it's an experience i haven't had
so i just have to
accept that people have had it
i would just point out that our minds
are clearly capable
of producing apparent others
on demand that are totally compelling
to us right there's no there's no limit
to our ability to do that as anyone
who's ever remembered a dream
can a test i mean every night we go to
sleep
some of us don't remember dreams very
often but some dream
vividly every night and
just think of how insane that experience
is i mean you you've forgotten
where you were right that's the
strangest part i mean this is
psychosis right you're you have you have
lost your mind you have lost your
connection
to your episodic memory
uh or even your expectations
that reality won't undergo wholesale
changes a moment
after you have closed your eyes right
like you're in bed
you're you know watching something on
netflix you're waiting to fall asleep
and then the next thing that happens to
you is impossible
and you're not surprised right you're
talking to dead people you're hanging
out with famous people you're
you're someplace you couldn't physically
be you can fly
and even that's not surprising right so
it's
you've lost your mind but relevantly for
this
or found it you found something lucid
dreaming is very interesting because
then
then you can have the best of both
circumstances and
it's uh that then it can be kind of
systematically explored
but what i mean by found just to start
to interrupt is like
if we take this this brilliant idea that
language constrains us
grounds us language and other things of
the waking world ground us
maybe it is that you've found the full
the full capacity of your cognition when
you dream or when you do psychedelics
you're stepping outside the the little
human cage the cage of the human
condition
to open the door and step out and look
around and then go back in
well you've you've definitely stepped
out of something and into something else
but you've also lost something
right you've lost certain capacities
well just
yeah yeah in this case you literally
didn't
you don't you don't have enough presence
of mind in the dream
in the dreaming city or even in the
psychedelic state if you take enough
uh to do you have to you there's no
psychological there's very little
psychological continuity with your life
such that you're not surprised to be
in the presence of someone who should be
you should know is dead
or you should know you're not likely to
have met by normal channels right you're
you know you're now talking to some
celebrity and
it turns out you're best friends right
and you're not even you have no memory
of how you got there you know like how
did you get into the room you're like
how did did you drive to this restaurant
you know you have no memory and none of
that's surprising to you so you're kind
of brain damaged in a way you're not
reality testing
in the normal way the fascinating
possibility is that
there's probably thousands of people
who've taken psychedelics of various
forms and
have met sam harris on that journey
well i would put it more likely in
dreams not you know because
in psychedelic with psychedelics you
don't tend to hallucinate
in the in a dream like way i mean so dmt
is giving you a
an experience of others but it's it
seems to be
non-non-standard it's not like it's not
just like
dream hallucinations but but
to the point of coming back to dmt
the people want to suggest and
terence mckenna certainly did suggest
that because these
others are so obviously other and
they're so vivid
well then that they could not possibly
be the the creation of of my own mind
but every night in dreams you create
a a compelling or what is to you at the
time
a totally compelling simulacrum of
another person right and uh
that's uh that just proves the mind
that's capable of doing it now it's it's
uh
the phenomenon of lucid dreaming shows
that the mind isn't capable of
doing everything you think it might be
capable of even in that
space so one of the things that
people have discovered in lucid dreams
and i i haven't done
a lot of lucid dreamings i've i can't
confirm all of this so i can
confirm some of it
apparently in every house in in every
room
in the the mansion of dreams all light
switches are dimmer switches
like if you go into a dark room and flip
on the light
it gradually comes up it doesn't it
doesn't come up
instantly on demand uh because you know
apparently this is covering for the
brain's inability to
produce from a you know a standing start
visually rich imagery on demand so
there's i haven't confirmed that but
that was
people have done research on lucid
dreaming
claim that it's all dimmer switches uh
but one thing i have noticed and
you know people can check this out is
that in a dream
if you look at text you know a page of
text you know or or a sign
you know or a television that has text
on it and then you turn away and you
look back at that text the text
will have changed right there's no the
total is it's just a
chronic instability graphical
instability
of text uh in the dream state and uh i
don't know if that you know maybe that's
someone can confirm that that's not true
for them but that's whenever i've
checked that out that has been true for
me it keeps generating it
like uh real time yeah from a video game
perspective
yeah it's render it's rendering it's
re-rendering it
for some reason what's interesting i
actually i don't know how i found myself
in this sets of uh that part of the
internet
but there's quite a lot of discussion
about what it's like to do
math on lsd because apparently
one of the deepest thinking processes
needed is those of mathematicians or
theoretical computer scientists
basically doing anything that involves
math is proofs
and you have to think creatively but
also deeply and you have to think for
many hours at a time and so they're
always looking for ways to
like is there is there any sparks of
creativity that could be injected
and apparently out of all the
psychedelics the the worst
is lsd because it completely destroys
your ability to do math well
and i wonder whether that has to do with
your ability to
visualize geometric things in a stable
way in your mind and hold them there
and stitch things together which is
often what's required for proofs
but again it's difficult to
kind of research these kinds of concepts
but it does make me wonder
where what are the spaces
how's the space of things you're able to
think about
and explore morphed by different
by different psychedelics or dream
states and so on
and how's that different how much does
it overlap with reality
and what is fundament what is reality is
there a waking state reality
or is it just a tiny subset of reality
and we get to take a step in
other versions of it we tend to think
very much
in a space-time four-dimensional there's
a three-dimensional world there's time
and that's what we think about reality
and we think of traveling
as walking from point a to point b in
the three-dimensional world
but that's a very kind of human
surviving
try not to get eaten by a lion
conception of reality
what if traveling is something like we
do with psychedelics and meet the elves
what if it's something what if thinking
or the space of ideas as we kind of grow
and think through ideas that's traveling
or what if memories is traveling
you